so many of us want to do work that we're
truly passionate about so i tried to
help three of you quit your job and
pursue the dream of turning your passion
into a business
first was leon he was at stage one just
lost he's working as a cloud manager
what he's really passionate about is art
and creativity but the problem is
i don't know if anyone is going to pay
me 20 bucks for this
so how can you turn that passion into a
business i think there is a scenario
where
what you really enjoy which is this art
and then also what people are willing to
pay for
there is something where these two meet
it's really your job to find
where is the overlap because there are
artists that
make money on topic yeah as long as
there are people that are doing what you
want to do
it's possible so find role models that
you can learn from
are there any people that you look up to
right now that do what you want to do
i don't know if you just hear it from it
the the nft
yeah that's people is a perfect example
he created a piece of artwork every day
for 13 years
amassed a following of millions of
people and recently sold his artwork as
an nft
for 69 million dollars and in his
comments you see other artists making a
living
from their creativity with a bunch of
different
art styles endless opportunity if that
is really what you want to do long term
then i think the best way to get your
name out there and
find a bunch of opportunities that then
later on show up is to just
make stuff and put it out there every
day making one thing and posting it on
instagram
just like the nft guy that would be
awesome i mean why haven't you done it
so far
you have to do it really long time but
every time you try it and then
in a few weeks you're just not that
interested anymore
then you just get stuck and just stop
for a long time and then start again
does that sound familiar to you you get
really excited about something then you
slowly lose interest and then you stop
sticking to it to be consistent you need
a clear action plan and a commitment
to get you through the times when you
don't feel inspired and in the end
a commitment is really just a decision
that we can make at any point
to change our life forever there's
always a fork in the road in life
and every moment we have the choice to
go one way or the other when five years
from now
where would you end up if you don't
commit to this
and really picture it like where would
you be and where would you be in five
years if you do commit to it
you have success you have more
confidence you commit to more
that's the crazy thing we always have
that choice but without any commitment
i'm kind of lost what is something that
you think you could commit to that would
absolutely change everything for you
i set myself every day something new
that i have to draw
at least for like 10 minutes the only
thing is that
you got to commit to it for at least a
year posting consistently without
expecting
any result really studying the platform
and
in a year from now you will have some
sort of result in three years from now
you can have a million followers there's
nothing really stopping you because
there's people that are already doing it
and have already done it what's
something that you can do to commit to
it as you might have seen in the video
where i help dan with his phone
addiction i like to set up a system that
forces you to take action by asking a
friend to hold you accountable
to take that daily action and if you
don't do it you have to give him money
so that's what we did how much 100
who would hold you accountable to that
my flag army what's the next step
tell them about it get an instagram
accept yourself a
starting goal few days into april
start in a few days you say couldn't you
start today
canada i'm just yeah i could you have to
walk in the road
right now i'm just scared to go to
the next step you know why don't you
make a commitment to me right now
number one you're gonna make your first
drawing tonight
number two i want to see a contract
if you miss a day you give your buddy
100 bucks i want to see it signed by you
and your buddy okay sounds like a good
yeah yeah
why not how do you feel right now good
you always have the choice to make a
commitment to go from feeling lost to
feeling determined he sent me the
contract and his first drawing that
night but let's check in again with him
later in this video to see if he stick
to his commitment and if not
how we can get him back on track stop
heads up before we move on i'm looking
for an assistant who is super passionate
about youtube who wants to join me on
this channel here in austin my goal is
to eventually build the number one
community for those who want to live a
truly fulfilling life so if you want to
join me on this mission and move to
austin
i'd love to hear from you back to the
video zach was in a different position
let's call it
stage two the grind he had already
started a side hustle while working
full-time as a software engineer
i created a series where i was
documenting every single week of me
starting an smma business that went from
no money while i had my
job to nearly a hundred thousand dollars
in revenue i burnt out i stopped making
videos
and then i fell back into the nine to
five i decided if i'm going to do
something i'm going to do something the
way i want to do it and that's a youtube
channel
this is where so many of us get stuck
because it seems so hard
but it doesn't need to be what is the
problem is it just procrastination is it
burning out
that's it what am i going to post the
answer is i have no clue what i want to
do
do you think anyone would be motivated
to get done if they
have no clue what they're doing no
so it seems like you are doing exactly
what you're supposed to so there's
nothing really wrong with you right now
why would you be motivated if you don't
know where things are going we think of
procrastination as this evil monster and
all these
motivational instagram posts tell us to
just crush it but what if it's just a
completely normal symptom
of an entirely different problem you
don't have a procrastination problem
you have a clarity problem what if
procrastination is always
just a friendly reminder that we need
more clarity
whenever you feel overwhelmed or you
procrastinate clarity is
always step number one clarity on what i
really want what are clear and simple
action steps i can start with
clarity on what results can i go after
that really motivate me what i see with
a lot of people is that they think they
have
a certain flaw that others don't have
and i've seen that a lot in you now
especially when it comes to
procrastination we think others are just
super disciplined and we think it's our
flaw that we're not
and we think we just need to do it but
it's physically impossible for our
brains to release the chemicals that
move us to take action
when we have no direction or clarity
whatsoever and please this goes so deep
do not click off now problem lizen you
always telling yourself oh there's
something wrong with me
i'm hyper critical of myself man and to
add to that
so is everyone else and tell me honestly
were you just thinking oh
i'm hyper critical of myself unlike
other people
yeah that's the problem everyone is and
that's where
i'm normal whether you believe it's a
unique personal problem to you
or a normal obstacle that everyone faces
as well
makes a huge difference in perspective
think about it if it's a problem that
everyone else struggles with
but people deal with it's manageable
it's doable it's like oh that's one of
these things i get it i got it too yay
but when you
when you have the problem yourself if
you think you're the only one struggling
with it it feels
impossible exactly zach five points for
gryffindor and what i've learned is that
the more personal the problem seems
the more universal it is most depressed
people think everyone else is happy when
in reality
most of us struggle with mental health
at some point in our lives socially
anxious people think they're awkward in
a social
setting when in reality everyone is
awkward but the difference is that the
confident people
know that everyone is so it's fine as
long as you think it's a unique personal
problem
it remains a problem correct me if i'm
wrong but should the goal right now be
to figure out what content you want to
make and stick to
so you you figured that out by kind of
just guessing and bending my head
against the wall and crying myself to
sleep at night
okay that's that's really it just like
most content creators out there if
you're feeling lost
you don't know what you want what your
passion is what career you should pursue
this is how you do it i used to make the
comedy stuff and i was like i don't want
to do that
i don't want to be the clown but it gave
me another data point cool that's not it
that's already checked off then i tried
some challenge type videos then i also
realized hey i don't want to just make
videos where i do
crazy stuff i want there to be a meaning
behind it so it's like all these little
data points that
i added to it i get more clear on what i
really enjoy what i really want
i delve deeper into this in this video
here in case you want to check it out as
well
so on top of procrastination there's the
perfectionist problem it's just going to
be painful because like you're going to
spend all that time on the video you're
going to feel so good about it and then
it's going to get like 50 views
depends what you're focusing on are you
doing this to grow your youtube channel
or are you doing this
to figure out what content you want to
make and building your skills
that's a very important point you just
made listen my fellow perfectionists we
always have an
expectation or a benchmark for what
success means and we have to be careful
of what that benchmark is because let's
be honest your first videos
products businesses dance moves whatever
they're gonna suck
so if your benchmark is that you need to
get a certain result that is mostly
outside of your control like getting a
ton of views or customers you're almost
guaranteed to be demotivated very early
on because you can't meet that benchmark
in the beginning and that's when you
struggle with taking action because you
just don't have the skills yet to get
these results
so you think you have a perfectionist
problem when the problem is actually
that you just set an unattainable
benchmark
so what if instead your benchmark for
success is that you get a little better
each
time and you build more skills and as
long as you do that
you're winning here you have immediate
wins because the learning curve in the
beginning is
enormous and it's completely in your
control you make progress you feel like
a winner and guess what
you'll be insanely motivated when you're
starting out early wins are crucial and
whether you feel like you're winning or
not depends on the benchmark that you
set
wow i love that that's it's easing the
gas top so much
exactly gives you that freedom to to to
make mistakes and to just have fun i'm
guessing that these
are the same exact motions that you went
through nope um
i banged my head against the wall
grabbed myself to sleep at night and it
took me a long time to figure it out
again he thought i easily figured it out
while he was struggling with it
everyone struggles with it so what do
you think would be a good action plan
moving forward
if i'm gonna break this down into
something that's actually tangible just
think about my next video
use the data i have to make the best
judgment i can
set a deadline and then do it so what's
your next video
i have this idea i'm gonna submit the
video by next friday how do you feel now
i feel i feel energized man isn't it
weird how motivated he seemed after
getting some clarity and realizing
there's nothing wrong with him
soon after zach publishes video after
months of not uploading and it is miles
better than what he put out before
because he clearly focused on improving
his skills
if that continues to be his focus he'll
become incredibly good at it and the
results will follow but what if your
side hustler is already making money
when should you quit shervin was in this
position let's call it stage three the
leap of faith
he's been reviewing health products for
high performance while also working
full-time as a product manager
i hope my my job isn't watching this yes
but he wants to go all in on his passion
but i feel like i should have at least
like six
thousand of income per month
consistently and how much you're making
now with the affiliates you said was
around two to three thousand damn so
you're already halfway there
uh yeah i guess so what are your
personal expenses right now do you need
the 6k to do it full time
what's currently holding you back from
going full time now i
yeah i fear but how much money do you
really need to quit your job i wanted to
determine that number so he doesn't just
keep
raising the bar as his business is
growing because i've seen people who
stayed at their job even though their
side business was making double their
salary but fear was still holding them
back
if you made three thousand dollars per
month consistently
would you then do youtube full-time as
long as i knew i could grow that number
yes
okay so the number is not actually six
grand a month it's
three thousand dollars per month yeah
from like a basic life needs
i could live off of it and chase this
dream and just by getting clear on that
we cut the goal in half just think about
the money goals that you set you may
need way less than you think to live the
life that you want and then you can get
that quicker from there create an action
plan
the question now becomes how can you
make sure that the money that you're
making now
is consistent and stable i have enough
money saved where i could potentially
fund myself for like let's say two years
i haven't pulled the trigger yet
two years yeah i think so i have savings
for 12 months
and i'm not making any money right now
so i need to make it happen
let's say you quit your job you focus on
youtube you do it for six months
it slowly starts going down then after
six to 12 months you're like
okay i'm gonna have to get a job again
could you easily get another job that
pays well
yeah definitely getting another job
again is that worse
than working the job that you are right
now in theory it
feels worse i would consider it a
failure because i went back and got
another job
so rock bottom is getting another job
again and having another job again which
is
where you are right now yeah
so you only really have something to
gain yes so what's really holding him
back is not necessarily the money but
the meaning that he attaches to having
to go back to a job which he considers
to be a failure
would it really be a failure it'd be a
lesson you could also say
you know what all these co-workers that
might be making fun of me right now and
say oh i told you
so you know what i stood up against them
and i took the leap which
most people would never do who does that
that's just a different way to interpret
this event so there seem to be no big
downside to it
what's the downside you get another job
and you are where you are right now
this is not an irreversible decision you
can always just oh didn't work out the
way i thought it would and go back to
where you are right now
it's very true i guess what's the risk
and the upside if i don't quit my job
and i stay
i guess the upside is anything
anything's possible right i could have
10 20 grand a month of revenue
i think it's just fear literally just
fear whether he decides to do it or not
it's
totally up to him there is no right or
wrong only he knows what's best for him
either way he's in a fantastic position
meanwhile leon has posted consistently
on his new instagram account without
missing a single day if you also want to
be featured on this channel like these
guys then you can check out the link
below
and if you want to work with me
privately i'm opening up a few spots
because it's something that some of you
requested
see you in the next one
[Music]
you